here's how i made one million dollars  this year as a solo serial entrepreneur  i wake up at 5am every day i meditate  for 30 minutes i journal for 10 minutes  i practice gratitude for 5 minutes i  love you i do my daily jog while  listening to naval's podcast on how to  get rich i sign up for a drop shipping  vip master class i get on a call with my  mentor like i got my entire fist in  there it's crazy  sorry what was your question i work 60  hours a week in social media marketing i  invest that money into crypto i run a  drop shipping business selling socks i  write a personal finance newsletter with  affiliate marketing i sell a course  called how i make 1 million a year in  your 20s i do consulting calls for 500  an hour i bought three properties and i  flipped them and my dad gifted me one  million dollars for my birthday  and that's how you make 1 million a year  in your 20s